alors madame vous avez vous un appel
très précis à lancer oui moi je voudrais
m'adresser à
toute personne pouvant donner un
renseignement fournir une piste un
indice est-ce qu'à l'époque certains ont
peut-être eu peur de parler est-ce
qu'ils ont pas osé dire où ils ont pas
su dire est-ce que les enquêteurs aussi
leur faisaient un peu peur je leur
demande je leur supplie qu'ils appellent
parce que par cette supplication c'était
Évelyne qui s'adresse à eux et j'attends
on attend que ça ce soir
8 décembre 1987 à Avignon dans le
Vaucluse
il est 17h30 une jeune lycéenne prend le
bus pour rentrer chez ses parents
elle s'appelle Evelyne boucher elle a 16
ans
[Musique]
elle fait le voyage avec une camarade de
lycée Christelle quelques minutes plus
tard les deux jeunes filles descendent
au même arrêt à Villeneuve-les-Avignon
descendent ensemble du bus le bon
parcourir plusieurs centaines de mètres
se séparer et Évelyne va devoir encore
cheminée dans la nuit durant plusieurs
centaines de mètres
au même moment la maman d'Evelyne Gisèle
est en train de préparer le repas elle
attend sa fille qui ne devrait plus
tarder
seulement les minutes passent et Evelyne
n'arrive pas
et puis ce jour-là
8h ou elle car 8h elle n'était pas là et
elle n'était jamais en retard donc à
l'arrivait toujours à l'heure si elle
était en retard elle téléphonait où elle
faisait prévenir
donc là j'ai commencé à dire c'est pas
normal qu'elle soit qu'elle soit pas
rentrée
Gisèle et son compagnon Jean-Pierre sont
inquiets la mère d'Évelyne commence par
rappeler son ex-mari le papa de la jeune
fille peut-être la lycéenne s'est-elle
rendue chez lui sans prévenir seulement
elle n'est pas chez son père
Gisèle décide alors de partir à sa
recherche elle commence à circuler avec
son véhicule pour essayer de
d'apercevoir sa fille de voir si pour
une fois elle n'aurait pas oublier si je
puis dire de rentrer à l'heure
regardez faire le tour de la rue de la
République dans les bars dans la rue
donc faire le tour le tour et puis
jusqu'à un moment donné où on est rentré
et on a dit bon là j'ai dit il faut
aller au commissariat pour
pour faire part de sa disparition parce
que c'était pas normal qu'elle soit
qu'on n'est pas nouvelle et que et
qu'elle soit pas rentrée
vers 23h30 Gisèle seront donc au
commissariat pour faire part de ce
retard plus qu'un normal
mais les policiers ne sont pas vraiment
inquiets
sur le moment ils nous disent vous savez
la saison certainement une fugue et moi
je dis non non c'est pas une fugue ma
fille ne fume n'aurait pas fugué ça j'en
suis sûr c'est pas une jeune fille qui
est coutumière des des fugues des
soirées tardives c'est pas dans ses
habitudes non alors au contraire une vie
extrêmement réglée précise
[Musique]
les policiers finissent par enregistrer
la plainte Gisèle n'est pas pour autant
rassuré et une longue nuit d'angoisse
passe alors
le lendemain matin vers 7h45 au lieu-dit
du plan de la dame deux chasseurs
parcourent les sentiers campagnards
quant au beau milieu d'une clairière il
découvre soudain un corps humain
c'est une jeune fille couchée sur le sol
face contre terre
[Musique]
son corps est à moitié dénudé
c'est la police judiciaire d'Avignon qui
prend en charge l'affaire sur les lieux
les enquêteurs font les premiers relevés
d'indice
l'état du corps
et une ballerine
on voit à l'oeil nu qu'elle a été
frappée elle a une marque sur la en
dessous de la pommette
[Musique]
et le médecin légiste voit qu'elle a été
achevée par une bonne qui a été tirée
sur le lieu parce qu'il y a un
épanchement sanguin on est manifestement
dans le cadre d'une affaire de d'un
crime sexuel c'est à dire d'une jeune
fille qui vient d'être violée et qui a
été ensuite assassiné un crime sexuel
d'une rare violence sur la personne
d'une très jeune femme
l'affaire est grave les policiers
inspectent alors les alentours à la
recherche du moindre indice pour
identifier la victime
il y a un cartable d'écolier à côté côté
du corps tout de suite on se rend compte
que c'est la jeune fille de Villeneuve
l'histoire
qui a disparu la veille
tous les vêtements de la victime sont
inspectés mais à part un blouson taché
de sang les policiers ne trouvent aucun
autre indice
les hommes de la police judiciaire
décident aussitôt de prévenir Gisèle la
mère d'Evelyne
[Musique]
là
je reçois un coup de téléphone
qui me dit
[Musique]
on a des nouvelles de votre fille restez
chez vous on va venir
quelques heures plus tard les policiers
se rendent chez Gisel ils ont déjà
raconté leur découverte à son compagnon
Jean-Pierre et c'est lui qui annonce la
terrible nouvelle
compter sur le moment quand Jean-Pierre
m'a appris donc son décès j'ai
eu un malaise
j'avais pas du tout imaginé ça
je comprenais pas quoi
je veux vraiment je comprenais pas ce
qui a pu lui qui avait pu faire ça
je veux dire pourquoi pourquoi la tuer
pourquoi la tuer
et bon ça c'est vrai que je me suis
toujours posé cette question là en me
disant bon mais c'est que
si il a fait ça c'est que elle l'avait
vu quelque part où elle le connaissait
[Musique]
dans les jours qui suivent la nouvelle
de la mort d'Évelyne fait le tour de la
région
la population est en émoi on est dans le
summum de l'horreur une jeune fille à la
fleur de l'âge les parents sont très
inquiets on ne sait pas qui c'est qui a
commis le crime on ne sait pas s'il ne
va pas recommencer donc tous les parents
ont peur
face au choc les enquêteurs se doivent
de faire vite
une information judiciaire est ouverte
et l'enquête est confiée au juge
d'instructions Christian Lernoud pour
qui elle devienne priorité car lui aussi
craint que le meurtrier ne soit
quelqu'un de la région
quelque chose de très fort ce produit
avec ce sentiment
que quelqu'un
de proche peut-être de familier ou alors
un rôdeur inconnu qu'on aurait le plus
grand mal à découvrir mais qui peut être
encore à proximité et dans la nature et
qu'il faut le trouver rapidement
deux jours après la découverte du corps
le médecin légiste rend ses conclusions
il apparaît que la victime a été tuée à
l'aide d'une arme de calibre 22 long
rifle
[Musique]
c'était un crime froidement commis
prémédité
on ne pouvait pas le dire mais en tout
cas exécuter avec une grande sauvagerie
et une grande détermination
[Musique]
l'autopsie confirme également que la
jeune Évelyne a été violée
[Musique]
des traces de sperme on peut être trouvé
sur le corps de la jeune victime et qui
ont déterminé qu'elle avait également
été
violée
puisqu'il y a eu une relation sexuelle
ou des relations sexuelles manifestement
sous la contrainte
seulement à cette époque il n'est pas
encore techniquement possible
d'identifier un ADN à partir d'un
échantillon de sperme on ne pourra donc
déterminer que le groupe sanguin du
tueur
à ce stade de l'enquête les policiers
ont donc très peu de pistes à exploiter
et c'est en s'intéressant à la vie de la
victime qu'ils vont essayer de
déterminer l'identité de son meurtrier
[Musique]
qui était Évelyne boucher qui
fréquentait-elle et qu'a-t-elle fait le
8 décembre 1987 jour de sa disparition
au premier jour de l'enquête les
policiers se plonge dans la vie de la
jeune fille une vie de lycéenne
apparemment sans histoire
c'est une jeune fille très sympathique
donna bord facile un petit assez
populaire tant vis-à-vis des autres
élèves que vis-à-vis des professeurs
rien dans son histoire qui laisse
supposer qu'elle est des relations
particulières qui pourraient conduire
quelqu'un à
elle est pas dans la drogue elle est pas
dans le
dans d'autres milieux non elle c'est une
jeune fille comme toutes les autres en
revanche la vie sentimentale de la jeune
fille était loin d'être banal
on sait d'avancer tout de suite par ses
camarades parce qu'elle était pas
secrètes donc un pythmique à 17 ans et
elle est amoureuse d'un garçon de café
qui d'abord 21 ans deux histoires
d'amour en même temps Évelyne a un
amoureux officiel Salvador un jeune
lycéen mais elle est également amoureuse
en secret de Donato le serveur d'un bar
où elle aime se rendre après les cours
avec ses copines
pour les policiers la piste est
intéressante les policiers se disent
c'est peut-être une fille un peu plus
légère que ce qu'on peut la présenter au
premier abord
est-ce qu'elle aurait
plusieurs copains en même temps est-ce
que elle passe de l'un à l'autre est-ce
que elle joue un petit peu avec avec les
avec les jeunes gens comme il y avait
deux garçons sur le coup on a pensé on a
pensé évidemment que ça aurait pu être
une histoire de jalousie les enquêteurs
s'interrogent la mort d'Évelyne
pourrait-elle être liée à une querelle
amoureuse avec l'un de ses deux garçons
Salvador ou Donato
pour le savoir les policiers vont
essayer de reconstituer l'emploi du
temps de la jeune fille le jour de sa
disparition le 8 décembre 1987 et ils
vont aller de surprise en surprise
ce 8 décembre comme tous les matins
Évelyne part de chez elle vers 7h30
mais grâce aux témoignages de ses
camarades de classe les policiers
établissent que contrairement à ce que
pensait ses parents Evelyne ne s'est pas
rendu au lycée ce jour-là il se trouve
Kevin ce jour-là elle a séché elle est
pas les palais en cours comme elle
aurait dû aller c'était une bonne élève
c'était une élève assidue mais qui qui
séchait aussi les coups elle prend cette
initiative de manquer quelques heures de
cours parce que le veut à tout prix
essayer de voir et de passer un instant
avec son l'homme le jeune homme dont
elle est amoureuse Donato
Évelyne passe donc toute la matinée au
bar Le Carnot à observer le jeune
serveur Donato
elle ne quitte le barque pour aller
rapidement déjeuner à la cantine de son
lycée
ensuite elle retourne au bar car elle a
l'intention de déclarer sa flamme au
serveur ce qu'elle fait dans
l'après-midi de jeune homme Donato va
accepter de pendant sa pause d'aller
boire un verre avec elle dans un autre
établissement ils vont passer un moment
mais lui bon ça l'amuse mais il a pas
envie d'avoir une relation avec elle
c'est un amour platonique lui ne répond
pas à cette à cette avance parce qu'il
l'a considère comme étant beaucoup plus
jeune que lui
d'ailleurs bien volontiers parce que
tout de suite après elle va avoir son
petit copain donc elle a fait pas une
maladie après ce rendez-vous Evelyne
retrouve son petit ami officiel Salvador
et il passe une heure ensemble
enfin vers 17h30 Evelyne quitte son
petit ami pour prendre son bus
Donato et Salvador semblent donc n'avoir
eu aucun contact avec Evelyne après la
fin de l'après-midi on est 100 ans
et sérieux
et ces garçons ont été
leur emploi du temps a été minuté donc
le soir ils étaient chez eux tous les
témoignages se recoupent pour confirmer
cet emploi du temps il n'y a pas de il y
a pas la place au moindre doute la
moindre interrogation
Salvador et Donato sont donc lavés de
tout soupçon mais l’emploi du temps
d'Evelyne réserve d'autres éléments plus
surprenants encore
vers 18h30 Evelyne et son ami Christelle
sont descendus du bus avant de se
séparer sur le trottoir
or les policiers découvrent que
quelqu'un assistait à la scène il s'agit
de Géraldine une autre camarade
d'Evelyne elle se trouve à la fenêtre de
sa cuisine
elle voit Évelyne s'éloigner seul
mais ce n'est pas tout quelques minutes
plus tard elle voit Évelyne passer en
sens inverse à bord d'une voiture
une dizaine ou deux minutes ou un quart
d'heure plus tard donc je regarde à
nouveau par la fenêtre et je vois
Évelyne assise à l'arrière d'un véhicule
donc c'est une petite voiture
du style R5 et donc elle est assez à
l'arrière et la voiture passe en roulant
très lentement devant chez moi donc
comme je suis très curieuse parce que je
suis étonnée de voir que elle sort en
début de semaine un soir parce qu'à
l'époque on était mineur donc
normalement on restait chez nous on
faisait nos devoirs et on rentrait
directement
Géraldine et même capable de donner une
description succincte du conducteur
on a donc un créneau très précis du
moment de l'agression de la disparition
de la manière dont Eline Boucher est
emmené plus ou moins degré plus ou moins
de force par un inconnu dans une voiture
au moment où elle rentrait dans son
autisme
l'ennui c'est que la description du
véhicule faite par Géraldine n'est pas
assez précise
[Musique]
à l'époque il y a beaucoup de Renault 5
il y en a énormément c'est la voiture
c'est la voiture classique à l'époque et
donc voilà ils vont ils vont chercher
ils vont chercher ils vont chercher
c'est une tâche absolument énorme c'est
vraiment chercher une aiguille dans une
bol de foin
mais la maman d'Evelyne Gisèle estime
qu'il s'agit là d'une piste trop
sérieuse pour baisser les bras elle
décide alors de mener son enquête de son
côté je relevais toutes les plaques
d'immatriculation étrangères au
lotissement je donnais les plaques à
vérifier à l'API parce que je disais
tiens peut-être que cette voiture a pu
venir ce jour-là elle pousse et elle
porte un petit peu tout le monde les
policiers le magistrat instructeur et et
son avocat avec son compagnon Gisèle
placard de des affiches partout dans la
ville afin de récolter des informations
sur la mystérieuse R5 ou n'importe quoi
d'autre promettant une récompense de 200
000 francs 30 000 euros
mais aucun témoignage nouveau ne viendra
récompenser leurs efforts et c'est la
police judiciaire qui va enfin mettre la
main sur un suspect potentiel
les policiers commencent à se demander
si l'assassin d'Evelyne n'est pas un
voisin de sa famille en particulier
parce que ce quartier est peu fréquenté
et difficile d'accès
pour venir chez nous c'était
relativement difficile donc c'était
quelqu'un qui connaissait le lotissement
et qui avait si c'était pas quelqu'un de
lotissement qui avait peut-être des
attaches dans le lotissement pour les
enquêteurs c'est à local c'est quand
même quelqu'un du coin
et l'enquête va s'orienter dans un
premier temps sur une enquête de
voisinage un petit peu serré sur sur
l'environnement sur les gens qui
habitent dans ce secteur et puis des
gens qui le fréquentent des jours durant
les enquêteurs investissent le
lotissement
ils ont fait du porte-à-porte ils ont
été orgés tout le monde ils ont bien
entendu en interrogeant
certains vérifiées leur déclaration et
parmi les habitants du lotissement il y
en a un qui va attirer l'attention des
enquêteurs
il s'agit d'un chauffeur routier d'une
quarantaine d'années
il vit dans le quartier pas très loin de
chez Evelyne et surtout l'homme a un
lourd passé criminel il a passé cinq ans
en prison pour agression sexuelle
les policiers décident de le mettre
aussitôt en garde à vue et l'homme ne
semble pas surpris d'être soupçonné
j'ai pas besoin de lui dire est-ce que
tu as tué la jeune fille c'est pourquoi
il est là il dit j'en étais sûr je vous
attendais
je savais que vu mon pedigree j'allais
être soupçonné
ma foi en lui dis on verra
les questions des fils interrogées sur
son emploi du temps le routier jure que
le soir de l'agression de la jeune
Évelyne il se trouvait au volant de son
camion dans le nord de la France pour
vérifier ses déclarations il suffit aux
policiers d'étudier son disque de
conduite celui que tous les routiers
possèdent dans leur camion or le disque
est formel le soir du meurtre le routier
était bien présent dans la région
d'Avignon il a donc menti son disque qui
n'est pas conforme à sa dette à sa
déclaration du coup il bombe un petit
peu embêté pour justifier
d'où il était et les policiers pensent
tenir là quelque chose de sérieux
pour conforter leurs soupçons les
policiers vont faire analyser le groupe
sanguin du routier si celui-ci
correspond au groupe sanguin déterminé
grâce au sperme retrouvé sur le corps
d'Evelyne ils pourront alors considérer
que le chauffeur routier devient un
suspect placovible
l'ennui c'est que l'analyse va livrer un
résultat bien différent le groupe
sanguin correspond pas c'est pas lui
c'est pas lui bon mais c'est pas lui
c'est pas lui c'est quand même un con
quoi parce que l'enquête marque que le
pas
et puis on a une personne qui était
vraiment un suspect qu'on pourrait dire
presque parfait qui est exclu
le chauffeur routier est innocenté
pour les policiers il faut revenir à la
case départ
près d'un mois après la mort d'Évelyne
c'est l'impasse
une impasse qui va durer plusieurs
années
[Musique]
février 1993 5 ans après les faits
témoin numéro 1 une émission de
télévision s'intéresse au meurtre non
élucidé d'Evelyne boucher c'est sa mère
Gisèle qui a décidé de participer à
cette émission pour relancer les
investigations alors madame vous avez
vous un appel très précis à lancer oui
moi je voudrais m'adresser à
toute personne pouvant donner un
renseignement fournir une piste un
indice
mais surtout plus particulièrement à
tous les amis d'Evelyne de l'époque
parce que elle avait 16 ans elle en
aurait 22 maintenant est-ce qu'à
l'époque certains ont peut-être eu peur
de parler est-ce qu'ils ont pas osé dire
où ils ont pas su dire est-ce que les
enquêteurs aussi leur faisaient un peu
peur je leur demande je leur supplie
qu'ils appellent parce que par cette
supplication c'était Évelyne qui
s'adresse à eux et j'attends on attend
que ça ce soir
[Musique]
c'est son espoir c'est elle a toujours
dit quelqu'un sait elle a deux deux
pistes c'est sensibiliser l'entourage
éventuelle de du meurtrier et puis qu'un
témoin qui avait vu quelque chose à
l'époque et qu'il n'ait pas dit pour des
tas de raisons viennent s'exprimer
viennent dire bah j'ai pas dit ou la
police est pas venue me voir où j'ai pas
voilà mais ça me rappelle quelque chose
malheureusement personne ne répondra à
l'appel de Gisèle ni le soir de la
diffusion ni les jours suivants
et les policiers commencent à manquer de
souffle à manquer de de pistes pour
pistes à exploiter donc on le dossier
n'est pas n'est pas enterrer le dossier
n'est pas fermé mais il est au ralenti
il est au ralenti une Renault 5
introuvable 50 d'enquête des pistes qui
s'évanouissent le moral des enquêteurs
est pour le moins émoussé seule la mère
d'Evelyne y croient encore il y en a qui
me disait arrête maintenant tu vois pas
que tu te
ça sert à rien c'est c'est fini les
années sont passées vous tu tu non je
disais non il faut pas il faut il faut
toujours avoir de l'espoir mais on sait
jamais un jour bon
et quelques mois plus tard ce sont les
progrès de la science qui vont donner un
nouvel espoir à la mer d'Evelyne
[Musique]
dans le courant de l'année 1993 la
police scientifique connaît une petite
révolution les laboratoires de police
sont désormais capables de prélever de
l'ADN sur des matières organiques et
notamment sur du sperme
on sent presse alors de faire analyser
le sperme retrouvé sur le corps
d'Evelyne et miracle malgré les années
écoulées l'ADN du tueur est clairement
identifié on a une trace certaine qui
est bien prélevé qui est bien conservé
et on va y arriver un jour ce n'est
absolument plus un groupe sanguin parce
que là c'est une une empreinte génétique
c'est une signature c'est une carte de
d'identité qui a été posée sur la
victime on sait que c'est une personne
et pas une autre
les enquêteurs disposent maintenant de
la carte d'identité génétique du tueur
il ne reste plus qu'à la comparer à
d'éventuelles suspects
on change de méthode c'est à dire qu'on
est plus sur la recherche de
renseignements sur la recherche de
témoins sur la recherche de
d'informations et ils vont procéder à
des vérifications ADN sur des très très
grand nombre de personnes les petits
amis de l'époque les le père le
beau-père
je suis passé deux fois l'ADN donc vous
voyez donc ça nous avait ça nous a
redonné ça nous ça rebooster parce que
on pensait qu'avec cet outil là
peut-être qu'un jour ou l'autre c'est
aboutirait comme les premières
comparaisons ne donnent rien petit à
petit les tests ADN s'étendent de la
famille aux proches puis aux voisins et
même au professeur du lycée d'Evelyne
le cercle va s'élargit donc c'est comme
ça que il y a 10 20 30 40 80 personnes
qui vont qui vont passer au crible de
l'expertise génétique et puis et puis
non tout ce sont négatifs en 1996 les
policiers vont étendre leur recherche au
criminels sexuels sur le plan national
c'est ainsi qu'ils vont faire une
découverte incroyable
Roberto sukho aurait séjourné dans la
région d'Avignon lors de son périple
meurtrier en 1987
celui qu'on surnommé le tueur fou a tué
7 personnes avant d'être arrêtée les
enquêteurs yvoient une nouvelle piste
intéressante
sukho aurait-il croisé la route de la
genive
on sait qu'il a la veille ou l'avant
veille des faits voler une voiture
Aix-en-Provence on sait que le jour où
le lendemain des faits avec cette
voiture il est vu dans le Vaucluse près
d'Avignon et on s'est surtout que un
mois avant en octobre
1997 il a agressé en Haute-Savoie violet
et assassiné une jeune femme
dans des conditions aussi barbares plus
troublant encore Roberto sukho tue et
viol quasiment de la même manière que le
meurtrier d'Évelyne boucher
il y a une similitude de Modus opérandie
à savoir des des femmes qui sont abusées
sexuellement et qui sont achevés qui
sont tués d'une balle de 22 Long Rif
dans la tête
les coïncidences sont troublants la
jeune Évelyne serait-elle donc une
victime
ignorée du célèbre tueur en série
le juge l'ère nous souhaite procéder à
une comparaison de l'ADN de Roberto
sukho avec celui retrouvé sur la jeune
femme seulement le magistrat se heurte à
un problème de taille Soko s'est suicidé
en prison en 1988 et il est enterré en
Italie
[Musique]
il ne faut vraiment pas écarter cette
hypothèse
et on décide de demander aux Italiens
l'autorisation d'exhumer le corps
d'Auber tuto
une fois l'autorisation obtenue les
enquêteurs se transportent en Italie
près de Venise
un OS est prélevé sur le corps de
Roberto suko et permet de comparer son
ADN à celui du meurtrier d'Évelyne sauf
que voilà le test s'avère négatif là le
coup est quand même très fort parce que
réellement réellement avec les derniers
enquêteurs qui ont encore la mémoire du
dossier nous sommes découragés
nous ne savons plus où chercher il y
avait un grand espoir mais
il a mieux valu que ça soit pas sous que
parce qu'il était mort nous on voulait
un quelqu'un de vivant Roberto Soko n'a
pas tué la jeune femme chez les
policiers le désespoir gagne du terrain
c'est quasiment irréel de se dire que
bon si le l'auteur est dans le coin
comment ça se fait en 19 ans on n'est
pas tombé dessus qu'il a pas récidivé
mais pourquoi pourquoi on est passé à
travers
80 tests ADN se sont révélés tous
négatifs
plusieurs pistes qui semblaient
prometteuses n'ont abouti à rien
en 2002 le juge l'air nous est muté dans
une autre juridiction mais son dernier
acte sera de faire enregistrer l'ADN du
tueur d'Évelyne boucher au tout nouveau
fichier national des empreintes
génétiques le Fnac une immense base de
données dans laquelle sont répertoriés
les ADN de délinquant et de criminels
à partir du moment où la trace ADN a été
versée au FNG elle va pouvoir être
vérifiée avec toutes les traces ADN qui
se trouvent dans les ordinateurs du Feng
c'est à dire que c'est c'est ça devient
colossal l'inscription était faite on
savait maintenant que peut-être un jour
une comparaison les aboutir maintenant
c'est c'est un peu une question de voilà
c'est la roulette c'est c'est parti
ce que ne savent pas les enquêteurs
c'est que le tueur d'Evelyne va
effectivement finir par être découvert
grâce à ce fichier informatique
16 mai 2003 au Pont du Gard nous sommes
à 25 km de Villeneuve-lès-Avignon c'est
là qu'un événement en apparence sans
rapport avec le meurtre d'Evelyne va
faire rebondir l'enquête
ce jour-là à la sortie du site
touristique un automobiliste est en
train de quitter le parking sans payer
en se faufilant derrière une autre
voiture
les vigiles ont aperçu la manœuvre
il y a vigile qui à ce moment-là bloque
le véhicule et là c'est une altercation
d'abord verbal le conducteur prétend
qu'il a simplement perdu son ticket de
parking mais il se montre agressif et la
situation dégénère rapidement
[Musique]
il y a des échanges de mots puis de
coups s'ensuit altercation physique
violente
s'en est pris ouvertement religieux
il semble de prédéclaration des vigiles
qui étaient méchés
et donc le l'altercation a été assez
violente à la suite de cette bagarre les
vigiles portent plainte contre le
conducteur un certain Robert grener
un an plus tard en 2004 l'homme comparé
devant un tribunal
au niveau du tribunal correctionnel il
va être condamné à trois mois avec
sursis
de la loi en lui dit monsieur vous avez
été impliqué dans des faits de violence
par conséquent vous devez vous soumettre
à un relevé de votre de l'empreinte
génétique autrement dit Robert grener
doit accepter un prélèvement ADN qui
rejoindra le fichier national
le problème c'est que Robert grener
semble quelque peu
récalcitrant alors il va pas vouloir y
aller tout de suite il va falloir y
aller tout de suite si
il répond pas aux convocations des
gendarmes après quatre refus ce n'est
finalement qu'au mois de mai 2005 que
l'homme va accepter de donner son ADN
lors d'un passage de la police
le prélèvement rejoint alors le fichier
des empreintes génétiques le fameux Fnac
et la vie de Robert grener reprend son
cours normal
du moins pour quelques temps
juin 2006
cela fait maintenant 19 ans Kevin
Boucher a été tué et voici que
l'ordinateur du FNAEG réagit enfin il a
découvert dans son immense base de
données un ADN qui correspond au sperme
prélevé sur le corps de la jeune femme
19 ans après
[Musique]
voilà ça ça coïncide il y a une
signature qui qui dit oui une signature
ADN qui correspond à l'identité d'un
sapeur-pompier qui en poste à la caserne
d'Avignon
sergent un pompier qui n'est autre que
Robert grener l'homme qui s'était battu
sur le parking
les résultats sont formels et fiables à
plus de 99,9%
on a peut-être retrouvé l'homme qui a
violé et tué Evelyne et sa mère a bien
du mal à réaliser je reste
complètement anéanti en fait on devrait
avoir une réaction
de dire ça y est ça fait 19 ans on n'y
croit pas on
réalise pas on est là complètement on se
regarde Jean-Pierre et moi complètement
abasourdi autre personne à base d'ordi
par la nouvelle le juge l'ère nous qui
attend œuvré pour que ce dossier soit un
jour résolu
19 ans après l'effet
c'est c'est le choc c'est le choc je
veux dire que dans ma carrière
c'est vrai que c'est l'événement le plus
important qui soit survenu parce que ce
dossier est hors norme par sa durée 19
ans après l'enquête est relancée il est
temps de s'intéresser de plus près à ce
pompier Robert grener
les enquêteurs se mettent au travail
pour en savoir plus sur ce pompier qui
est devenu leur suspect numéro 1 avant
de l'interpeller il souhaite récolter un
maximum d'informations sur son compte
il s'agit donc d'un pompier
professionnel qui travaille au centre de
secours d'Avignon et qui réside sur la
commune de Sorgues dans le Vaucluse
Robert est rentré dans les années 80 84
il est rentré dans dans mon équipe c'est
un pompier qui est à l'intervention
compétent et se donne
dans toutes les missions qui lui sont
confiées mais ce pompier respecté perd
de deux enfants possède aussi une part
d'ombre que plusieurs témoins ne tarde
pas à confirmer c'est un homme
plutôt porté sur l'alcool enfin et assez
violent qui qui supporte pas trop le
bien que les gens aillent dans son sens
et
il est assez violent il est assez la
cible beaucoup de demandes ont peur même
moi
cache pas que
une intimidé quoi parce que c'est jamais
où il pouvait en venir quoi et il y a
autre chose dans sa caserne Robert
grener a également la réputation d'être
un séducteur un pénitent on a eu des
éléments notamment de femmes qui
allaient à la caserne pour aller voir
d'autres amis et qui ont été pris à
partir par Robert grener et qui avait
assisté lourdement pour avoir leur
faveur sexuelle je faisais venir des
défis en casernes puis qui met lorsqu'il
avait fini ses affaires il aimait
embêter les autres dans les chambres
voilà faire faire du bruit quoi le
pompier ne manque pas de défaut et les
soupçons vont encore s'alourdir lorsque
les policiers vont découvrir qu'il
fréquentaient les mêmes quartiers
d'Avignon que la jeune Évelyne
tout d'abord Robert grener est affecté à
une caserne de pompiers rue de la
caretrie cette caserne se trouve à
seulement quelques centaines de mètres
du lycée Aubanel le lycée d'Evelyne
boucher
Robert grener aurait donc pu rencontrer
la jeune fille à la sortie du lycée elle
passait tous les jours devant la caserne
pour prendre son bus
autre coïncidence l'un des meilleurs
amis de Robert grener et domicilié dans
le même lotissement que les parents
d'Evelyne le pompier avait donc souvent
l'occasion de se rendre dans ce quartier
cela fait donc deux endroits où le
suspect et la victime ont pu se croiser
régulièrement
mais avant de procéder à l'arrestation
de graisner les policiers ont une idée
il décide de convoquer Géraldine
souvenez-vous c'est cette jeune femme
qui avait vu Évelyne le soir du meurtre
enlevé par un mystérieux inconnu au
volant d'une Renault 5
19 ans plus tard
reconnaîtra t-elle Robert grener
je vois quatre photographies qui
entourent trois zones différents trois
hommes que je n'ai jamais vu
et en bas de la de la page sur la gauche
il y a une photographie d'un homme une
espèce de déclic puisque quand je le
vois je lui dis mais c'est de c'est pour
lui que vous m'avez fait venir
quand je vois la photo j'ai une réaction
ça me parle tout simplement Robert
grener est identifié il est désormais
temps de passer à l'action
[Musique]
19 juin 2006 il est 7 heures du matin
les enquêteurs de la PJ d'Avignon se
rendent au domicile de Robert grener
pour l'interpeller
et l'homme n'ose aucune résistance
il semble même ne pas réaliser ce qui
lui arrive
c'est comme quelqu'un qui t'envoie du
placard il est complètement il fait la
personne complètement surprise il est
médusé il dit qu'il comprend pas on lui
montre la Commission à toi
la violée meurtre quand même sur sur les
faits donc je comprends pas c'est quoi
enfin pendant la perquisition de la
maison du pompier rien de particulier
n’est découvert ni armes ni coupure de
journaux mais il est vrai que 19 ans
après l'effet l'homme a très bien pu
faire disparaître tout élément
compromettant les enquêteurs font donc
tous leurs espoirs sur l'interrogatoire
le problème c'est que Robert grener
reste quasiment muet surtout quand on
lui demande connaissez-vous Evelyne
boucher faut dire que ça se passe très
mal parce que il se bute dès le départ
et donc ni l'évidence et puis pas du
tout s'expliquer et il n'y en bloc
il lâche rien
il dit rien il dit non c'est pas moi je
connais pas je comprends pas de quoi
vous m'accusez non je la connais pas
j'ai jamais vu on lui a montré la photo
et la connaissait pas
il connaissait pas le lycée aubanais il
avait jamais entendu parler cette
histoire les heures d'interrogatoire
passent Robert grener résiste
les enquêteurs abattent alors leur carte
maîtresse il lui révèle que son ADN a
été retrouvé sur le corps de la victime
mais là encore le pompier a une réponse
toute trouvée
vous me dites mon ADN qui a du sperme
moi les jeunes filles j'ai beaucoup de
rapport avec des des jeunes femmes je
[Musique]
oui je suis fidèle d'accord mais j'ai
pas meurtrier voilà
monsieur gremer avait énormément
d'aventures énormément d'aventures et
sincèrement il le dit je suis désolée
mais je ne me rappelle pas de toutes mes
aventures il ne se rappelle pas donc il
ne se rappelle pas de cette relation
lorsqu'on l'interroge en 2006 cette
relation 87 il ne s'en souvient pas
après 48 heures de garde à vue Robert
grener est conduit au palais de justice
de Nîmes et mis en examen pour le
meurtre et le viol d'Évelyne boucher
mais si le pompier a décidé d'en dire le
moins possible d'autres ne vont pas
tarder à parler pour lui
une semaine après l'arrestation du
pompier le commissariat reçoit une
lettre anonyme une lettre dirigée contre
Robert grener et certains de ses
collègues une lettre qui profère des
accusations particulièrement graves
ce courrier décrit des scènes odieuses
qui auraient lieu à la caserne qui
mettent en cause des sapeurs-pompiers
avec des rapports sexuels forcés avec
des viols avec des actes de cruauté de
barbarie sur des jeunes femmes des
parties fines d'une rare violence avec
comme maître de cérémonie Robert grener
en personne les policiers vont même
retrouver une de ces victimes une jeune
femme surnommée Cricri qui aurait subi
de graves sévices
est une jeune dame qui avait un retard
intellectuel
avéré et donc Robert grener en a profité
pour en faire un peu son objet sexuel il
lui faisait subir lui et puis certains
certaines de ses collègues un
sapeurs-pompiers il faisait subir à
cette femme des faits de de viol
particulièrement sordide
soit il a renvoyé ou soit et il était
arrivé déjà qu'il a prête à son copain
de chambrer le scandale de la caserne
d'Avignon est retentissant aux yeux de
l'opinion Robert grener devient un
monstre
pour les enquêteurs il n'y a plus de
doutes l'homme est forcément coupable et
le scénario de la soirée du drame n'est
pas bien difficile à imaginer
on se dit que peut-être avec Évelyne
boucher
soit bon il la connaissait et puis ça
dérapait parce qu'il avait bu ou alors
parce qu'il avait peut-être flirté au
départ et que ensuite il a voulu aller
plus loin qu'elle a voulu pas ou alors
carrément qu'il devait peut-être rentrer
en contact avec elle dans la rue
qu'il a peut-être éventuellement fait
monter de force dans son véhicule et que
bon bah à l'issue comme il était méché
il voulait avoir une relation sexuelle
avec elle et comme c'est refusé à lui
il a il a une relation de force et qui a
dérapé qui a dégénéré
20 ans après les faits de nombreuses
zones d'ombre demeurent encore les
policiers n'ont pas réussi à mettre la
main sur l'arme du crime et ils n'ont
jamais retrouvé la fameuse Renault 5
dans laquelle Évelyne aurait été enlevée
ils n'ont même pas pu faire la preuve
que greener et la jeune fille c'était
déjà rencontré
on n'a pas la preuve qu'ils
entretenaient une relation
l'on n'a pas la preuve chez lui de
la présence d'indices même 20 ans après
bien sûr le test ADN accuse Robert
grener mais faute d'autres preuves le
procès n'est pas forcément joué d'avant
ses avocats lui ont d'ailleurs annoncé
ils espèrent bien obtenir l'acquittement
cours d'assises de Nîmes le 7 avril 2008
lorsque Robert grener pénètre dans le
box des accusés la salle retient son
souffle
[Musique]
et tout le monde est contre lui
que froid
réservé et il se présente comme une
victime en fait pour la mère d'Evelyne
le face à face avec le meurtrier présumé
de sa fille et particulièrement
douloureux
face à nous
donc le premier jour je le regarde je le
fixe dans les yeux sans arrêt
et là c'est
ouais c'est c'est difficile à difficile
à expliquer mais c'est vraiment une
ambiance une atmosphère pesante
angoissante
qui vous ça vous détruit quoi
Robert grener demeure froid et distant
et d'emblée il clame son innocence il
n'a ni violé ni tué Evelyne boucher
Robert grener va se présenter à son
procès
comme un bloc comme il est un bloc c'est
à dire qu'il vient et il dit non non
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi
cette jeune fille je la connais pas les
femmes il dit qu'il en avait un qui
voulait il allait boire un café au
bistrot du coin et hop et en trouver une
et il montait dans la chambre c'était
très facile pour lui alors pourquoi
aurait-il violé
quand à la présence de son sperme sur le
corps de la victime Robert grener
affirme que cela ne prouve rien du tout
il explique même qu'il a sans doute été
victime d'un complot
peut-être c'est quelqu'un qui a pris mon
sperme dans un
dans un préservatif et qui est l'a mis
dans le vagin de et dans l'anus de la
jeune fille de l'adolescente
un peu quand même
impossible à réaliser les charges qui
peuvent sur lui ne serait-ce que l'ADN
c'est incontournable c'est le sperme
c'est pas celui du voisin ni le mien
c'est le sien
dès lors Robert grener ne peut plus
contester l'incontestable il va alors
totalement changer de position
du bout des lèvres il reconnaît
maintenant qu'il a peut-être eu une
relation sexuelle avec Evelyne boucher
mais aussitôt il ajoute qu'ils ne s'en
souvient plus et que de toute façon cela
ne veut pas dire qu'il a tué la jeune
fille qui est une relation sexuelle moi
je le conteste pas je ne le conteste pas
je dis que cette relation a pu avoir
lieu dans un contexte avant le jour même
voir la veille c'est tout à fait
admissible mais je n'en fais pas pour
autant le lien entre celui qui couche
c'est celui qui tue seulement le rapport
médico-légal affirme que le meurtre a eu
lieu immédiatement après le viol
version qui ne tient absolument pas
pourquoi parce que ça ne correspond pas
aux constatations médico-légales à
savoir que Evelyne elle a été violée et
qu'elle a des traces médicaux légales
qui sont plus que plus que parlante que
et que surtout on retrouve son corps
avec le sperme de Robert Greiner en
quantité importante dans le vagin sans
le moindre écoulement ce qu'il a sa
pensée qu'en aucun cas elle a pu
parcourir d'ailleurs on ne sait pas trop
comment le trajet entre la caserne des
pompiers d'Avignon et l'endroit où on a
retrouvé son corps c'est-à-dire environ
plusieurs 25 ou 6 km Robert grener
semble acculé le coup de grâce s'annonce
lorsqu'en fin de procès ses anciens
collègues pompiers se succèdent à la
barre pour dresser de lui un portrait
effrayant le décrivait quelqu'un
d'orgueilleux alcoolique violent
bagarreur
enfin triste si quand même monsieur
grener va être touché par les
déclarations de
de ses anciens collègues c'est dur pour
lui de voir l'image qu'on renvoie qu'on
renvoie de lui
il a l'impression d'être abandonné alors
que la course retire pour délibérer
Robert grener crée une dernière fois son
innocence mais a-t-il pu convaincre les
jurés
un homme a été condamné hier soir par la
Cour d'Assise du Gard à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour le viol et
le meurtre d'une lycéenne la
particularité de cette condamnation et
qu'elle intervient plus de 20 ans après
les faits à l'annonce de sa condamnation
à perpétuité Robert grener crie à
l'injustice mais tu vois pas
que il était persuadé qu'à la fin de la
semaine de débat il allait être libéré
il avait préparé c'est ça qu'à la maison
d'arrêt dans le camp adverse la famille
d'Evelyne et bouleversée vingt ans après
les faits justice a été rendue je crois
que
c'est son bras
de même Robert grener a fait appel de sa
condamnation le deuxième procès
confirmera la 100 ans
aujourd'hui l'homme purge sa peine à la
maison d'arrêt de Lyon
[Musique]